if your sister or your close friend has
a baby you're more likely to have a baby
in the year or two following and vice
versa if the people around you are not
having children you're less likely to
have children yourself there's always
been this assumption by demographers up
until birth rates started really
crashing in recent decades that people
would just spontaneously decide once
they had access to contraception or
whatever to have 2.1 kids that that was
like the natural settling point for the
human species that we'd all reach there
and we' just stay there and that's
clearly not true because so many
countries now are falling way below
replacement there no law of nature that
says that people should want 2.1 kids
people look around them and they're like
oh okay everyone here has one or zero or
six and then that becomes mtic desire I
think that becomes what's considered
normal and humans are completely
obsessed with what's normal we do
clearly have free will but I think that
what we consider to be desirable normal
the life template is so incredibly
dependent on what other people around us
think